so yeah I know it's like it's kind of a
study in naturalness okay so my base I'm
just gonna play with my footwork okay
I'll bring my feet in there they're
inside my hips can you see that okay it
now requires me to hold my balance I
have to actually micro adjust to flexion
mic reflections in my lower legs and
things like that okay if I just come a
little bit to where my hip joints are
then the naturalness comes in where I
don't have to do anything and it's it's
holding itself to see that you can
understand naturalness says I'm not do
I'm not having to do anything okay if I
raised my heel in the back foot like
really high then you'll see if I don't
do anything what's gonna happen I'm
gonna fall to that she caught you okay
if I put my heel down on the ground
right and then you'll feel the flexion
in the hip and then the front of the
knee right and so I have to be flexible
in order to do that but if I have a kind
of I find that heel angle where I can
just rest of this posture do you
understand that
okay then safety goes with the draw and
there's a natural way where my arm will
move if I start changing anything so for
example I'm going I'm going to come with
the sword all the way on the other side
this you'll feel a tension here because
that's a far reach it's a far reach to
go you don't even have to embrace the
tactical considerations of exposing
yourself and you know now you have to
get back to the center line after you
crossed it you you'll feel that that
that doesn't feel easy there's a tension
right here when that happens and as you
as you start to go the tension starts to
spread from joint to joint it's now a
natural feeling I bring this back here
and then this movement is easy to do and
it doesn't require anything out of my
shoulder but am i trying to draw the
sword from here then you'll feel the
tension again so the movement on this
new casket is I'm going to come out and
when do you when do you start to raise
the sword right before you feel the
tension will feel the tension so you
start to change the cycle of action okay
and now the same thing here I'm tension
free but if I start to do more right
you're gonna feel the tension tension
here you can tension here again if I
change if I take the sword out of it and
when I lean like this do I get to do
nothing no I have to micro adjust a
device I'm going to fall forward like
that do you understand so keep the base
natural move the arms so that you don't
have to
lean to reach out alright so I can't
reach out because that's gonna make my
base unnatural so I go as far as I can
natural and then I do this okay
and you'll find that you can do this the
whole way through so out the sword is
off same thing if I go here if I go
above my shoulder you'll feel the
tension you'll feel like that's not
natural there's a lot of pressure my
thumb I have to hold that there if I go
below my shoulder same thing you'll feel
a lot of tension on the heel palm to
hold the sword where you but if you can
hang out here just below shoulder height
this base and everything else is
actually keeping that point where I
needed to do okay so same thing if I
this angle on my wrist you're gonna feel
the tension so it's kind of like okay
wait okay is pushing on you that's
telling you where not to go
and by that telling you where to get on
what to do okay so the sword is like the
kick the base is like your breath inside
is like you kid
your mind is like you can when you feel
the unnaturalness the contestation the
resistance that's not where to go so I'm
here and everything should be natural
just hold it you should be outlining on
there all day long with no sore spot on
my thumb or on my feel or holding my
balance
okay and what we tend to see is that
people are caught on the final part of
the move because the goal not realizing
nor the goal is to learn the
move not to just have your sword out so
people make solutions do you see me now
at all okay
so practice enough calmly and now slowly
enough with enough presence so you can
feel oh I don't know I will do my back
my feet are up okay I feel a bite on my
thumb I feel a bite on my heel Tom I
feel a bite on my shoulder on my upper
back at my elbow at my wrist you're
doing it wrong okay